tonight
i'm doing my first club in london i'm
not really a club person i don't really
like clubs i'm in london i'm gonna try a
club i'm gonna try it once
but i'm gonna bring you guys a lot today
i'm kind of sad to be honest clubs is
such a single girl thing to do you miss
having a boyfriend
i miss him i'm in a sweatshirt
he and i kind of were like still talking
a little bit after we broke up which i
know you shouldn't do but it's hard when
you like still love someone you know and
while i know it's the right thing for us
to not be together
it's hard like when you love someone you
know it's like that person was your best
friend for a year
but i don't drink see as you guys know
when i go out
i'm not drinking because i've been
heartbroken before and i've dealt with
it with alcohol before and it's just not
i don't recommend it
because i i do think you can go out and
have fun with your friends
but
you're going to do stupid [ __ ] if you
drank yay
so not sad
okay okay so most of my subscribers are
men that watch me
and you guys always want to know what
goes on on a girls night out
i'm going to show you
everything
look at it they won't know everything
i'm going to tell you guys everything
don't tell her if you don't hang this
but i like pain you look hot
you look high to me
so the continuation of a girls night out
is being freezing outside waiting for
our ubers but there's a silver lining
hoes don't get caught
okay do a spin show the outfit okay
okay
all right how long have you been in the
streets before i'm not fourth straight
so yeah okay okay tell me how do the
streets feel you don't know yet
how long has it been since you've been
in the streets when was your last hot
girl so
my last hot girl summer was like
the pre-marriage period and that was
like 2017.
so it's been a long time
all right so we're doing a hot girl walk
across the street
so this is where we're at this is
tell when someone is from like the west
coast compared to the east coast no but
i can not yet but the more people are
here
and this is our first club experience
i've never been to a club before
i'm gonna take you guys with me um okay
so just a little bit of context i did
not realize that in the uk they
literally have their clubs and bars in
the basement so look at this i it looks
like a dungeon almost which is fine i
guess i've never
just seen a setup like this so i was
very surprised walking down i was like
where are we going what on earth is
happening
but but it wasn't as creepy once we get
downstairs you're gonna see part of the
girls night out part of a girl's night
out
is is we can't go to the bathroom alone
clearly so if one of us goes
we all go
what do you do if you see another girl
in the bathroom what do you say tell her
okay so this is what it looked like when
we first got to the club um one
difference i noticed is it was about
midnight and in the u.s
bars would be pretty crowded by then but
there it was like pretty empty you can
see
all right the men don't know but when
girls go into the bathroom together
we're immediately best friends
they're selfies
and we just
we just all become best friends
pearl here i have no idea why i thought
it would be a good idea to facetime my
dad in the bar but i missed him wanted
to talk to him and
yeah so this is the result of that i
[Music]
all
guess
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
america america
all right this is
[Music]
if you watched my last vlog you'll know
gabby had a boyfriend but they actually
broke up so this is a compilation of
events that happened relating back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think
okay
[Applause]
this has gotten out of control
[Music]
okay so so gabby is zero out of five
zero she did not have fun i should have
known better though because i really get
irritated with people touch me so
what did did you have fun i had a lot of
fun i had fun actually surprisingly
oh
i'm limping i'm limping out
but we're going off to get food
it's not worth it we're sneakers here
i'm not gonna lie
look at that
men don't appreciate us enough look at
this
ow
i have so many blisters on my feet when
i tell people i don't drink usually they
think i'm aborted i used to be an
alcoholic
and you know part of that's true
but
the other side
the other side of that is
i just was getting fat to be honest
and i was like something's got to go
it's not going to be dessert
i mean do you think you can treat him
like this and still get back with him
later
maybe maybe if you love him don't
i do love him but like he's just a
little bit dry
yeah he should probably learn how to
stand up for himself girls don't want to
walk all over their boys
they want to feel like
like there's
like you're a man and i don't
like here's the thing with me i will get
whatever i want because that's the type
of woman i am i want a man that like if
i like this is what my mom said for
example
you need a man that doesn't let you get
whatever you want
so if i say like i want to do this like
if it's not the right thing at the
moment or whatever i need a man will say
no and i will just be like yeah
no that's what
i think too like like guys will be like
oh nice guys finish last but i'm like
you're not nice guy you're a pansy yeah
like i need a guy to put me in my place
and then i can respect that because yeah
that's what i eat
all right we made it to mcdonald's
it's kind of fun how have the self
ordering things here
we don't really have those
uk richards
walker conversations
i almost had a heart attack i just left
this camera in the uber
oh thank god he came back this is my
door lady julia hi she's my favorite
if anyone's hiring she's trying to find
a new job
[Laughter]
she's like the hardest worker she works
so hard
but yeah this ass here so if anyone's
hiring
oh that was an adrenaline rush for the
end of the night but
happy and yeah happy ending
that was an adrenaline rush